hi i'm nikki hey guys so i'm geo hi my
name is chris hey guys i'm sam i
actually grew up in the philippines for
about 10 years i lived in the
philippines for the first 14 years of my
life i was born and raised in san
francisco i was born and raised in new
york city i'm actually half filipino but
i grew up at the filipino mountain
filipino grandma that cooked a lot of
filipino food for me growing up
so what adoba means to me is like just
like something authentic from home
something that you can just throw into a
pot let it simmer let it sit overnight i
let this sit for more than a day so it
really really sat into like the flavors
and stuff ooh
we got chicken drumsticks it's clearly
been sitting in the saucer while and
it's been marinated so the meat
underneath looks a little bit tinted
brown i'm gonna go for the rice and
gravy first i don't know if i'm supposed
to tear it with a spoon or eat it with
my hands
oh i'm definitely tasting some
peppercorns here wait that's actually
kind of good not really tasting much of
the soy sauce this one's pretty good
very classic very basic adobo i think
this is what i would usually get in a
restaurant this is pretty spot on the
chicken's a little dry and i noticed
that there's not a lot of sauce it
tastes a lot more salty than anything
the chicken's also got a nice sear to it
which i always appreciate it tastes like
either the soy sauce or the sugar in it
is a little bit burnt gonna have to take
off some points for that probably give
like a six it's pretty good i'll
probably give a seven it's still edible
i just it kind of was just way too dry
four out of ten i kind of want to finish
this but uh we got a few more so
i know my mom's so disappointed in me i
actually had to facetime her to make
this she didn't really give me
measurements she was just kind of like
add a little bit of soy sauce maybe a
little bit more vinegar things like that
i'm just like how can you tell one thing
that i decided to like go with was lemon
lime soda which really is just 7up it
doesn't matter how different or what
kind of like secret ingredients you use
it's really hard to like get it wrong i
think that the sauce looks really like
heavy this one looks really thick this
has got like a very thick and heavy
looking sauce like look at that
i do see a lot of peppercorns in here
you know i'll just try to avoid those
but i'll maybe have one everyone's doing
drumsticks is that like is that the
common one that people do let's just get
into it let's try it
so i take sauce back it's almost like
syrup there's definitely a lot of sugar
in this one it's a little weird but the
chicken is cooked pretty much perfectly
if you make drumsticks you're kind of
just gambling that they eat the right
part of the drumstick you know because
it's kind of a toss-up i like how big
the bay leaves are actually yeah i'll
probably eat this again but i might
reduce it a little bit less i think they
were probably running late and just
blasted the heat as high as it could go
probably over reduced a little which
explains your syrupy texture of it but i
kind of like that overall pretty good
probably give that like a six or six and
a half so that's like maybe seven out of
ten i'd give them nine
i'm pretty sure i'll be the least
filipino filipino person in this group i
do know how to cook though i just don't
know adobo so i just texted one of my
friends asking how do i make adobo and
she just said soy sauce vinegar and also
make it a day before so it soaks up all
the juices so i did that it looked way
better last night
i think i just got to microwave it or
something but dried bay leaves apple
cider vinegar i have black peppercorns i
put a lot on there actually oh i put a
lot of garlic all right so this is
chicken thigh i'm a little scared
because there was a lot of bay leaves in
that bay leaves is always good this
one's got a pretty good consistency to
the sauce not too heavy not too light
ooh the sauce is a little bit more thin
[Music]
i totally bit into a peppercorn there's
wow there's a lot of peppercorns peppers
like a little bit like too strong
there's just so much of it spice is just
hitting me now i like it though i'm not
gonna lie this does taste pretty good
i'm not sure like what it is but it's
got like a unique taste to it that i
don't really associate with adobo but
it's not bad the flavor just hits you
it's very saucy the meat is cooked
pretty well i like how soft it is
overall i think this is the best sauce
so far i don't know i feel like someone
who put that much bay leaves into it
hasn't had adobo before no adobo looks
like that that being said i think it's
pretty good i think this one's been
married in a little bit longer because
the sauce is like seeped into the meat
and this one definitely has some more
punch to it which i like i don't like
bland adobo i would have this again for
sure um so that's like definitely like
an eight out of ten the one thing it
lacked was a little bit more vinegar
probably like an eight and a half or
nine actually uh hits all the red spots
eight plus that one has to be my
favorite um eight out of ten
bay leaves black pepper cardamom all
spices are all like pretty common like
filipino ingredients but my grandma got
something called pickling spice which
actually has all those ingredients plus
a ton of other stuff in there that kind
of adds a lot more spice adds a lot more
punch and flavor to it i think that's
what makes this adobo like really
interesting and really special oh this
isn't chicken this is definitely pork do
people make adobo with non-chicken meats
i think it looks like
pork adobo and i see some onions in here
i also like how the baileys are like put
to the side on the right here appreciate
that they cut this up into tiny little
bite-sized cubes let's give it a try
this one has an interesting spice i can
definitely taste some peppers in here
definitely something a little different
one of those secret ingredient things
that i was talking about i don't know
what they did differently with this one
but it tastes different i like the
previous one because it's a little bit
more sweet because i like that like
brown sugary type vibe to like hit me a
little harder dry meat little cubes kind
of interesting taste recognizably adobo
i think that's pretty much all i have to
say about it i appreciate that it is not
chicken i would have this again for sure
that's also like a seven out of ten
cause that's something different uh so
i'll give it a five i'd probably give a
five
out of ten
[Music]
i was the last person i was expecting to
win this i didn't even measure anything
right i just seared the meat and started
throwing things together until it looked
right i'm like this is probably good and
i got the peppercorns and i'm like it
needs a little bit more and i just
dumped it in i'm like yeah that's good
so i don't know i guess i guess um thank
you for watching
[Music]